no big family celebrations no fireworks
in many countries this year people have
to forgo beloved traditions
because the pandemic is spiraling out of
control
here in germany that means lockdown
until january 10th
at the earliest non-essential shops are
closed christmas markets have gone dark
nightly curfews and alcohol bans apply
in places
and schools are shut the u.s canada and
the united kingdom have become
vaccinating
but their vulnerable citizens still face
grave risk
yet things could be different countries
like ireland
impose tough lockdowns much earlier and
are now
reaping the benefits our title
covid19 crisis who pays when the
politicians
get it wrong
hello and welcome to to the point and
it's a pleasure to greet our guests
matthew karnichig is the chief europe
correspondent for politico
and he says germany's covid19 policy is
economically exactly what the doctor
ordered
the new lockdown in the quiet season
couldn't have been
better and it's a pleasure to welcome
julia fisher
she is a berlin-based journalist and
physician who reports on science and
medicine
for radio broadcasters and her opinion
this year beloved traditions can have
life-threatening consequences
everyone who does not attend big
togethers
saves lives and it's great to have derek
scully on the program again he is a
correspondent based here in berlin with
the irish times
and he says ireland did it right in the
second wave
after a six week lock lockdown the irish
are looking forward
to a relatively relaxed christmas
and new year
so matthew let me start out by coming
back to the quiet season because it's
certainly not a quiet
season for medical personnel and for
many people
working in clinics and of course
intensive care
units more and more are under
strain here in germany what happened
well i think the government took overall
a fairly flexible approach over the last
several months in germany because they
didn't want to have
a hard lockdown like we've seen in other
countries in europe
in france and belgium italy and so forth
one reason is
because the effects that that has on the
economy and yes
now the numbers are rising in germany
but if you look back
over the past six months and if you look
at how the german economy has performed
and it's outperformed most of europe
it's done
surprisingly well with for example in
the third quarter alone
the um gdp rising by over eight percent
which
surprised everybody i think you have to
look at the
entire picture here and say you know yes
they could have done
a full lockdown and we would be in a
better place right now
at christmas than we would have
otherwise but there are also other
effects of a lockdown that people i
think often forget particularly on
mental health and um you know on
schools and and so forth so i think that
overall
germany should get pretty good grade
here
thank you very much uh we will come back
to the economic side in just a minute
but uh yulia you say
beloved traditions can have
life-threatening consequences so clearly
you think that the situation
here is pretty dire yes um and i think
right now it really is important to
really reduce
the contacts that we're having because
that is the one thing the virus really
attacks
and unfortunately it's the one thing
that that we really like we really want
to be together with other people but
this
uh this time we really just have to make
sure
not to see anybody who's not within our
epidemiologic
bubble unless we can really quarantine
before or something but we really have
to watch out this year
so actually there are some restrictions
or before these title rules there were
some restrictions that had been put in
place in mid-november
a so-called lockdown light that was
supposed to be a circuit breaker to
really
break through that chain of infections
but it hasn't turned out that way
why not it hasn't worked as as the
politicians had hoped because i think
they hoped that the people in germany
would act accordingly to those rules
more strictly we know that in march
people reduce their mobility
by 60 percent and they only reduced them
um to forty percent this time and that
is just not enough so we saw
that um different than in ireland for
example
people didn't work in the home office
enough they did travel with public
transport a lot and things like
that so in a whole that was
not able to really reduce the the number
as hoped in the beginning derek scully
you pointed out that
ireland did handle the second wave
differently so two questions about that
first one
how stable is the current situation
there i was checking
some news reports it looks like it's not
quite clear if the infection rate may be
trending upward again
exactly i mean i look at these lock
downs it's a bit like cortisone cream
you can put it on the rash the rash will
go away the question is how quickly will
the rash come back up and how do you
tackle the underlying cause
so these lockdowns are only ever
measures but it's almost like when do we
need the breathing space when do we need
the breathing space and timing it
accordingly
and i mean the irish christmas is
extremely important millions of
immigrants like to come home many of
them won't make it but
for at least people in ireland they've
had a very tough year they didn't have
the breathing space in the summer
the way we had in germany so to not give
them the christmas there would have been
a revolt so
i think they just counted backwards from
christmas six weeks and they said let's
do it but as you said this morning the
chief medical officer in ireland is
worried and things are creeping up again
but i mean the numbers
the comparable number is they're at 48
cases per 100 000 over seven days so
in parts of saxony and eastern germany
they're at 700 so
and in german i think it's like 100 and
670 so we're still a long way but yeah
it's going to creep up and people are
already saying
is the price of our christmas we're
going to be locked down in january again
but
people would say if i had a choice i
think january everyone's maxed out their
credit cards anyway sitting at home in
january is what they do best so
um maybe it would be less painful then
so yeah a lot of governments are just
making plans but i i did see what
ireland
they had a calendar in front of them
they counted backwards and in germany
they just seemed to like
all right yeah christmas forgot about
that and now we're sort of facing into
this and
for retailers for families to be told
with two days notice oh by the way
christmas shopping is cancelled i mean
the panic having people panicking
running into shops grabbing whatever
they could
in the middle of a pandemic really
doesn't seem very smart and they knew
christmas was coming
matthew if you compare say the way that
germany handled
the first wave to how it's handling the
second one
do you see a change in the way that
politicians have behaved here in this
country
i would say i see more a difference in
the way the population
has behaved because people seem to be
much less worried
about corona now than they were
in march because they didn't have the
visibility when something happens for
the second time
you tend to be less worried about it if
you've survived the the first stage
and i think that's what's happened here
where most people
understand that you know even if they
get it their chances of dying are
not that high and you know they know
what they need to do to avoid getting it
back in march the whole situation with
the masks for example wasn't really
clear if that was good or not there was
just
a lot of confusion about it so i think
you know people tend to blame the
politicians but i think that we all know
now and we knew back in march
that there was going to be a second wave
there's always a second wave there was
with the spanish influenza
in 1918 and there is now do you
think that's right julia would you say
actually politicians do bear part of the
responsibility
certainly there was some criticism about
mixed signals that had been sent here in
germany
say uh when rates started trending
upward again in early october yeah and i
think that is that
that was definitely a problem i mean
it's i think also it's very true that
people are getting used
um to the virus and that because there's
still a lot of people who don't
know anybody who really got very sick
from the virus or anything i think
that that helps people or makes people
underestimate the danger of the virus
much more than it was
in in spring and i think that's a big
problem but i also think
it would be the duty of the politicians
to communicate in a better and clearer
way
that the danger is still there and that
we have
that we have to act together to do
something against this pandemic and i
think sometimes in some parts of the
country that went wrong
derek whether or not ireland
is the perfect example certainly some
countries
do apparently do better than others new
zealand
taiwan some other places in
asia to what extent do you think that
the approaches in such countries
are transferable to others are there
recipes here in terms of political
guidance communication and so on no i
think the social element is crucial i
mean
and it's also what works at what point
uh you know the german approach
they had they were able to test quickly
they had the capacity
early on tracking and tracing that and
they were also decentralized so they
could act locally and in this
particular phase the decentralized
approach appears to work less
i think a crucial issue is um how much
can a state expect of its people and
um i don't know enough about asia but
people have said that there's a higher
level of compliance with
you know an order comes and people are
more willing and western europe is more
notion of personal freedom you know
you're infringing on my personal freedom
ivan i'm entitled to
celebrate christmas as i wish in ireland
what i found interesting i found
fascinating was the level of social
control is so much higher
there than here in germany um there's a
meaning um people could be shamed into
doing things
more quickly i mean shame was taken out
it was like an instinctive
irish catholic holdover i don't know
what but people could be shamed into
staying at home oh you're going abroad
it was never illegal to go abroad but if
you were going abroad you would hear
about it from your neighbors afterwards
so
again that's not sustainable but it's
certainly in the first stages at work
and there's sort of a social social
cohesion and i notice in germany things
seem to be at least in berlin which is
not germany but
um a much more individualistic approach
you know there's a notion of society but
this
people aren't as close to each other so
the consequences of your personal
decisions
perhaps are not as immediately apparent
to you or you care less about the people
in your
immediate environment who could be
affected by your personal choices
let's drill a little bit deeper on the
economic side
of the pandemic the difficult trade-off
that we face is of course not only about
foregoing beloved traditions but also
very much about material costs germany's
new
lockdown will have severe consequences
for retailers in particular let's go to
nuremberg
known for a christmas market whose magic
has now abruptly come to an end
golden angels mulled wine shopping the
epitome of german christmas especially
at the world-famous crist kindles marked
in nuremberg
this year it's cancelled only a few
stalls are open
selling fruit and vegetables to the
handful of customers
we have american wine there's no
christmas here there are no tourists
anymore it's just plain bad
as you can see the market is completely
quiet
people should only leave their homes in
urgent cases
alcohol is banned in public places and
there's no nighttime curfew all enforced
by the police
germany hesitated to impose a hard
lockdown for a long time
and it was preceded by an unusually
emotional appeal from the chancellor
if we have too much contact over
christmas and it turns out to be the
last one with our grandparents we would
have failed
and that is something we should not do
in fact according to surveys around 70
of germans are in favor of a hard
lockdown
but how long can people hold out
and let me ask matthew karnick exactly
that question because your opening
statement indicates that you think
germans are in a good position to bear
the costs but the retailers association
here in germany says that as many as one
in two retailers could wind up facing
bankruptcy if they don't get enough
help quickly well fortunately germany
isn't primarily a retail
economy and i think people often forget
this because
you know when you go out on the street
what you see are shops and when
uh shops are suffering that's something
that's more immediate to most people but
it is
and has always been an industrial
economy it lives
from exports and that has continued
german exports to china
and elsewhere in asia are back up again
recently
so i think this is what the government
has really focused on and
that's why i think that being more
flexible over the past several months
has been
a good idea because this is a crucial
phase
for most industrial companies the end of
the year particular
the fourth quarter and so while
retailers are hurting
i mean the lockdown started on december
the 16th so they're going to lose
maybe a week or so of their normal
business which is also a crucial time of
year for them
but overall i think the trade-off is
probably
worth it because if you had started the
lockdown earlier closing schools for
example that would have had a much more
severe impact on the core of the german
economy
derek the german government says that it
will help affected businesses
cover their fixed costs to the tune of
another 11 billion euros a month
apparently from the public purse the
finance minister says that's okay
germany can afford this astronomically
high
debt do you think that's right um well
the
the finance minister in germany the
federal finance minister is a social
democrat and coincidentally he wants to
be elected chancellor next year so
um i mean i think it's everyone wants to
be the christmas everyone wants to be
santa claus at the moment but yeah i've
had friends who aren't in politics
aren't in finance they just said where's
this money coming from
um so if the man on the street is
beginning to wonder where the money is
coming from
rather than saying isn't it great we're
getting free money um
it's that's worrying for me and germany
i suppose it can afford it more than
other countries because
for the last couple of years it was
almost like a religion here they call it
the schwarzenegger the balance but they
wanted this black zero the
books had to be balanced but um suddenly
in the in the crisis they've been able
to
because they're bound their balance
sheets were more balanced over the years
and it's able they're able to take money
but even by german standards this is
astronomical amounts of money it'll be
certainly interesting what they can
promise next year
running up to the election the federal
elections in september if they've
actually
blown all the money now julia
looking at this trade-off between
economic
burdens and the burdens on health
systems because of the pandemic
do you think there really are
alternative approaches
i'm thinking about countries like sweden
or switzerland which tried hard to let
normal life
go on and essentially uh that way
preserve
the openness of the economy those models
essentially
have failed haven't they yeah that
didn't work i mean we saw that the
swedish had um many more deaths than we
did
and and that the economy didn't live
better
than it did in germany so um
i think it's always it's always very
difficult
to to balance these two options but
um scientists know that if you have a
hard lockdown and you keep it
short but strict normally it is good for
the numbers
and it doesn't hurt the economy as bad
as if you if you keep
low measure measures or light measures
for a long time
so i think um doing a hard lockdown now
and hoping that it can be short
is better than yes keeping it going on a
fairly high number
there is one model here in germany that
is sometimes seen
as an alternative to the way that most
states are doing things
and it's coming from the fairly small
southwestern town of tubingen where the
authorities
green party politicians have made a very
big effort to protect
the elderly and the vulnera vulnerable
for example by creating special times
where only
they can shop and meanwhile allowing
life otherwise to go on pretty much as
normal
would you say that is a model that could
work elsewhere at least in germany
it is a nice model to really try to
protect the elderly more
but it's never gonna prevent the virus
from getting
to the to the risk groups because people
mingle and you always have young people
working at hospitals or
um social care homes and stuff like that
so you're
it is a nice try and i'm sure it has a
good effect but it's not going to stop
it's not going to stop the dynamic of
the virus spreading also into the other
groups
matthew in many ways this discussion
encapsulates
what we saw in the united states
essentially
in the tensions between a donald trump
who said just
let the economy do its thing and the the
pandemic will kind of
eventually fizzle out to a joe biden who
says the economy is never going to
really get back on its feet
until we get the pandemic under control
which side would you come down on
well i think the economy is going to
start prospering again in the coming
months as the vaccination
starts to roll out we're seeing that
already i think we're seeing more
optimism
in the united states because of that
that's also reflected in the stock
market which is sort of a harbinger of
sentiment going forward you know trump
didn't manage the crisis well it's clear
if you look at the number of people who
died in the united states with 300 000
now dead and 3 000 dying every day as we
uh speak now so i don't think that was a
success that said the economy has
performed better than in many other
countries because there wasn't
a uh harsh lockdown um
and you know this i think is is a
situation that is different in every
country
you have to listen to the people there
are different mentalities around the
world
obviously china was very successful in
combating the virus they have methods i
think that
most people in europe would not accept
but they did succeed in bringing the
pandemic under control very quickly so i
think you just have to
be somewhat flexible starting with
massive uh surveillance
and use of private data i want to come
to the vaccine question in just a moment
but
derek one more um political aspect
and that is um popular support for the
measures we saw in the report
and i've seen this myself i was out on
the streets yesterday talking to people
70 80 percent of germans saying they
support this new lockdown they think
tighter restrictions are
important should have maybe been put in
place sooner
merkel has seen her popularity skyrocket
yet again
since she's been calling for these
harder measures but the fact is
that is now what is it likely to look
like
in six months or longer if people are
losing their jobs
if retailers are failing could we see
a backlash in which people lose faith
in the politicians and perhaps turn to
populism
um i think it's very likely i mean i
find it interesting that there were
enough people out on the streets
yesterday to do a vox pop i mean
technically we're not supposed to be i
came here
through the western city center and i
was expecting another sort of zombie
film
scenario like in march where just
abandoned streets and a bit of rubbish
blowing in the wind
people are out and about and if you ask
them everyone has a good reason to be
out the question is oh yeah well of
course there are restrictions so
i think what we're seeing is this sort
of cognitive distance in people's minds
of course i know there's restrictions
but i just need to a bit like that
person who parks in the second lane
i just need to i just need to get my
bread rolls i just need to go to the
bank machine
and so i think that exceptionalism we
all have this exceptionalism in our mind
and uh
i think that's growing in in in march
february
uh march april people were just saying
no i mean there's no exceptions we just
have to address it so we're already now
in quite an elastic
phase in our brains and that could go on
and i i don't really think the populism
i think that's more interesting in the
anglo-americans party the christian
democrats they're looking for a new
leader
and it'll be interesting who wins there
and will it be a more authoritarian
figure will it be more a
we need to uh like a merkle figure um we
need to keep everyone together
integrationist figure
so i think that will be key we'll see
that in the middle of of of january and
i think that will be an interesting
barometer of where german public opinion
is
this is the largest party this person
who's going to be elected is probably
going to be the next chancellor
and they will set the tone i think for
the debate
let us now take a quick look at pandemic
politics some countries that have
largely
failed to get the pandemic under control
such as the u.s
and britain are now hoping that
vaccination will put things right
the united kingdom was the first country
in europe to
approve biontech pfizer's vaccine and it
is
accelerating its rollout margaret keenan
a 90-year-old woman from coventry
made history as the first to be
vaccinated she's happy to have put kovit
behind her and hopes that many will
follow her example
her shot kicked off the largest mass
vaccination in british history the
elderly
and nursing home staff are first in line
for the vaccinations julia based on that
british example do you think that
authorities here
could and should have accelerated the
approval process
and rolled the vaccine out faster i
don't think so because
i think it's really important uh to to
make the people see that this is um
a process that's really following
protocol and that all the standards that
need to be applied are applied and that
the people can really
trust if if it's approved this vaccine
they can trust that it's good and for
that reason i think it's it's okay that
it's taking a while
and derek how fast would you expect
britain's
program to show results do you think a
quick rollout can begin to compensate
for those failures that were in fact
made
by johnson's government i think he
actually
what we're seeing with the vaccine
rollout is a sort of cross-infection
brexit realities it's a disastrous
situation things are getting really
tough
they needed some political um they
needed a good news story
so i would be very surprised if there
weren't some phone calls made to say we
actually need the vaccine and we need it
now
and the health minister went on british
television and was crying crocodile
tears how moving it was to see this
so i think there's a political reality
to to be that and of course there is a
political reality of the deaths in
britain i've been asking my
british cousins like why is nobody
talking about the death rate here i mean
this is like
grenfell and hillsborough and all of the
terrible disasters in britain
on a daily basis and he's not so yeah
he's on political under political
pressure to deliver uh but
in the long term it would be terrible if
if for some reason this emergency
um um allowing them back to come to an
emergency rules if that backfires and
public credibility is
the credibility of the vaccine is
undermined will he take the political
responsibility for that knowing boris
johnson i'd say probably not
matthew politicians here are warning
that it's going to take a while
for vaccines to truly bring the
infection rates
down the germany's health minister says
we might see a return to normalcy in
summer
do you think that's right is it
realistic
certainly realistic it might not be
realistic to
think that everything is going to open
up again on january 10th which is now
the official end
of the lockdown that might need to be
extended but i think by the time summer
comes around again
i expect things will have calmed down by
then hopefully the
vaccine will have been rolled out to
many people not everybody who's going to
need it but
we'll be on the right path and i think
the world will look much different
and uh julia just because we're almost
at the end of our show let me come back
to our title we asked whether
citizens must pay for politicians errors
we have a long hard winter before us
before that vaccine really does begin to
show
results what would you want to see from
politicians here in germany but also
in europe as a whole in terms of trying
to keep people on track
to keep the pandemic at least somewhat
under control yeah i
really think it needs a euro-wide and
really
clear strategy we need to really
formulate a goal that everybody is
working to for towards and then we need
clear communications by the politicians
and we need the people to follow the
rules and really act
um accordingly derek last sentence what
would you want to see from leaders
yeah european union solution that's what
europe is here for it doesn't the virus
doesn't care whether it's in belgium or
across the border
an hour away in cologne and yet we're
dealing in the national level and that's
catastrophic in the long term thank you
very much to all of you for being with
us
thanks to you out there for tuning in
see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you